Welcome to today's hot topic from
intelligence squared.com who has got it
right.
Does liberal democracy need you to get a
thick skin or does it need a strong
state protecting us from extreme verbal
assault?
Here are some highlights from Wendy
kaminer confronting Femi [inaudible] as
they thrash it out.
We start with femi defending curbs on
hate speech,
less,
less hate will be bread and so we would
have less to fear.
I think that hate speech can certainly
be a contributing factor to bigotry and
prejudice.
And I'm,
you know,
I'm not a,
I'm not here defending the merits of
hate speech,
but I,
I,
you know,
as I said,
I think it is always much more dangerous
and I also think that it's morally wrong
to criminalize speech that we don't like
because we have some sense that in the
long run it's,
it's going to be,
it's going to cause decide or harm.
People should be given the right to
speak yes to the point where it violates
the rights of others.
People may be given the right to express
their concerns about principles,
but not about individual characteristics
of people.
I personally am grateful and proud to
live in a country and to be part of a
nation that does not tolerate hate
speech.
And there's anything I would say that
perhaps our restrictions and keeps me in
the UK.
I've go far enough if I can take this
opportunity to respond quickly to some
of the things that family.
So first,
I,
I really appreciate her forthrightness
in questioning why we need to have
freedom of speech,
because that's not a statement that you
will generally hear from people in the u
s to defend hate speech regulation
because here,
um,
it's,
it's not really so acceptable to say,
I don't believe in free speech.
Please visit intelligence squared.com to
see a full selection of our performances
and debates on free speech.